hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land on
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and in the previous video
you could see us setting up a lot of
basic infrastructure like water and
electricity but one of the main things
we never really made was a toilet so up
until now it's mainly been like this in
the bushes
without the pants
so yeah kind of basic so in this video
we're gonna make a compost toilet and we
also have the first person helping for a
longer period of time
ian from the us to actually help to
build this toilet and on top of that
we're also going to use some recycled
plastic so uh
so this is where we're going to make
room for our first outhouse it's uh it's
about 100 centimeters wide so something
like this
um and we want to start it
it's going to sit about here and go into
the forest more but while we're at it we
might as well just take care of all of
this
[Music]
do
[Music]
there you go
today i'm going to be
leveling out the area that we cleared
earlier
um it doesn't have to be perfect because
we're likely
laying down some gravel
um to separate the
the platform from the soil but
it's pretty
aggressively sloped right now so
we have to do something about that
so uh
yeah
let's get started
[Music]
so
[Music]
we
just unloaded all of the lumber
into our stockpiles here
um let's go on a journey to see
how
well well-cut these are
[Music]
next is squaring
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
from here it was on to checking our cuts
and building our frames
and i had a lot of really good help from
alex as you can see we've finished
building out the framing except for the
door that we'll do when we assemble
and
the next step is to oil to make sure
that
our wood does not rot
[Music]
this poor little grasshopper look at him
i recommend you you bounce somewhere
else do there we go
[Music]
now that the bottom of our platform is
well oiled we're going to
move all of our frame pieces to the end
destination of our outhouse
and start assembling
[Music]
do
so now we've cut our siding stock down
to size
and we're going to install
do
next was assembling the roof and i had
another wonderful little helper for this
part
in the meanwhile dave constructed a
toilet seat box
uh cutting a hole using measurements
made off of the toilet seat and with a
raised floor to bring the poop bucket
close enough to the hole
that there could be no room for any
messy splashes
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo
so for the toilet seat we wanted to try
something experimental so we looked on a
precious plastic map and reached out to
studio smelt from amsterdam and they are
gonna make the seeds from recycled
plastic
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
look at that
oh man i don't even want to get the
knife near it i'm scared i'll nick it
look at that pattern
so you don't see the food in it
i don't know that we're gonna be allowed
to poop around this it's so nice
oh dang they went
they went all out
we have our selection
i guess we did say we're gonna make two
eventually
look at that
i feel like we're going to be spoiled
[Music]
[Music]
so now as you can see we've finished our
composting toilet let's take a tour
[Music]
we've got our
bucket of sawdust that we
bought from a local lumper mill
really really cheap
it's perfect biomass for maintaining the
moisture levels that we're going to need
and also for keeping down the smell
once things you know go down
we have our toilet paper of course
and we have our really beautiful toilet
seats made from pressed plastic from a
precious plastic workspace out in
amsterdam
um
this beautiful
white speckled with colors and
contrast black garbage white speckling
and uh to demonstrate you know
sit down
and do our business
after you're done
you take a scoop
put it down the bin
because this is our first
uh we're gonna do a little bit extra
just to make sure that the
base has a nice layer of
sawdust before anyone poops
cool
now let's go out back and see
how the
exchange process works
we have a very handy hatch right here
after everyone's done their business and
it gets
full enough take it out
have everything inside
bring this to our composting location
um
add it to the the
pile that would be the active one where
we're putting all of our current
processed or currently uh added
poop np
um
next to a a composting pile one that
will sit for six months or a year
just to make sure that all pathogens are
killed it's safe to use
our hatch is really well built it has a
nice stops
built in so
it's very easy to
uh orient it right under the toilet seat
yeah
so we have
a composting toilet now we um it's quite
an upgrade from having to find places
around the property
uh make sure you don't step in somebody
else's poop
uh
and
with that uh i have some business of my
own to attend to
we're gonna do the first poo
yes
right now
all right so that was it big upgrade
actually feels super nice to have this
uh we're not really sure yet what to do
with all the resources we create still
figuring out and what is the best system
for that so we'll see more about that
later
for now thanks a lot for watching if you
like what we do make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com
i'll see you in the next video
instruction manuals